[Música]
y
en ese espacio porque es un honor
estar en este bonito escenario
y también mencionar a votar la
modificación y atreverse a aventar en
este ruedo regularmente el director de
cine está detrás de cámaras y es muy
fácil pero estar en frente de la
situación ahora entiendo los mis actores
habrán escuchado mi nombre es cierto que
soy un chavo de veintiún años y varias
personas me han dicho que he
desarrollado dos carreras
una de manera institucional que es
ciencias de la comunicación en la
universidad la salle más pachuca es
séptimo semestre y otras de manera
directa o como me gusta llamar está
hecha la palabra es aprender que es un
caso a todo grafía este que he
desarrollado mi ópera prima que es una
película independiente y estos dos
factores son muy importantes actividad
porque deriva de esta charla el placer
de ser uno mismo
actualmente es un reto ser uno mismo y
en mis cortos años de vida creativa
y me gustaría iniciar
con esta profunda que ocurre cuando ver
esto
[Música]
más
muy importante en mi infancia y mi
adolescencia
hay estas pequeñas celdas
yo tuve un problema del lenguaje
grandísimo yo no podía pronunciar
absolutamente nada y lo que hacía
[Música]
estar en el problema durante seis años
de primaria pues la mayoría de mis
compañeros
de los grupos sociales después
los deportes
el adobe cambiar cuando estaba en mi
casa estaba en mi cuarto y juguetes
bien
y podía expresar pero yo decía es que
solo estoy jugando pero sin darme cuenta
estaba haciendo cine
estas son mis primeras películas en
corto
mis actores
y agregaba música
por eso también hace complicado ver con
los otros niños porque entonces
[Música]
entonces aquí está el contraste de ser
uno mismo en infancia repito que
normalmente
como regalo de santaclós llegue a este
tema no está en mi vida
cambia mi destino
de una forma positiva también tengo que
mencionar que en el 2011 esta secundaria
afortunadamente el problema del lenguaje
desapareció por las terapias pero
principalmente por mi mamá ella me dio
todo el proceso
complicado porque gracias a ella
[Música]
algo que nunca me imaginaba
entonces ya teniendo el tema de
cualquier resuelto y con este mal
si están más locos que yo por apoyarme
es todo
[Música]
como joven adolescente
que empiezan a gustar las niñas quiero
pertenecer a un grupo social de
caballeros y todo eso
atractivo y demás
durante un año de servidores
casualmente el cuerpo reaccionado porque
gm ese mismo año
y estaba limitado
y me sentía muy solo y me sentía solo
por qué
y el típico muy importante somos un
chino
millones pero la esencia es difícil para
demostrarle a tratar
y yo lo que estaba haciendo
[Música]
y francisco
me recomienda porque no vas
porque yo creo que para distraer
y cuando los vídeos
vivo
y desde ese momento pretende importancia
de ser más
[Música]
retomamos
ocurre que tus decisiones
y por lo tanto de manera eterna
las personas
[Música]
no vas a buscar en los externos son
lindos o bárbaro
ser tú mismo
otra te vuelves maestra dura
te genera un alto conocimiento porque
eres capaz de analizar tus virtudes y
llevarlas a inter pero también tus retos
los analistas y los vuelves en una área
de oportunidad
y para convertirlos sus virtudes
ser tú mismo puedes objetos hoy
generales
obviamente todo esto es una película de
años
[Música]
así que ser tú mismo
estos son los pilares
a mi familia que siempre han superado
sus ideas
mis amigos quienes tabasco si ellos o yo
por por apoyarme
mis maestros que siempre me han dado
el conocimiento es para usarlo mejor y
aprovechar que me dan consejos con toda
su experiencia
y equipación
y es ser uno mismo
así que qué ocurre cuando eres tú mismo
21 año de años de esfuerzo pues puedo
decir que
el éxito
y es que retomó la palabra esencia
cuando tú creas cualquier cosa cualquier
producto
[Música]
cuando tu esencia que aclaramos que es
indica ese año ya va a ser creativo
innovador porque viene de ti y el
ejemplo es la película que son 100
personas que están detrás de este
proyecto pero 10 personas más o menos
pero las cosas
porque yo contaba la idea
[Música]
con
y si se puede hacer como proxy se pueda
y esa energía
así que porque hay personas
hacer ustedes mismos
así que muchísimas gracias
y muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]